[Music]
I'm the one
Our Guest today Roland Martin American
journalist and uh he's got a show called
Roland Martin unfiltered and he's known
to be the sweetest guy you'll ever meet
specifically on YouTube
interviews just very gentle kind my mom
says that have you always been this
sweet of course always my mom says that
my dad says it is it just two people how
many more until I get pissed off I get
pissed off until folks lie to me on the
air and the other side comes out so let
me ask you how long how long have you
been like this like at what at what
point were you the kid that argued every
Point were you like uh Linda Linda Linda
you don't understand like were you that
person from day one because it was
always a Pursuit Of Truth
um and so I mean I remember being in the
was a couple of things I was probably in
the
third grade yeah third or fourth grade I
remember at an elementary school it was
it was kindergarten teacher who uh these
these girls said I said something to
them that I never said so they go to him
they complain and so we had this huge it
was a Vanguard magnet program with this
huge basketball game so it was like the
Vanguard program versus the regular
school it's like the biggest game of the
year
and the guy was like oh he said well I'm
believing them so you have to apologize
We're not gonna play in the game
guess I ain't playing a game so I
literally sat there and remind you this
is like the biggest game of the year
it's like a major deal so my brothers
he's in the Vanguard program and I'm
dressed and everything so I sat there
for three periods yeah
yeah I didn't move I'm like dude how old
are you how old are you at this I was in
the uh that was either third or fourth
grade probably it was probably it was
fourth grade and I was like I'm eight
nine years old I was like I'm not moving
I didn't say it so my whole deal is you
know some people like dude just just say
I'm sorry who you can play the game no I
didn't say it so therefore I'm not gonna
sit here right and apologize now when I
was in uh 12th grade government class it
was a trip with uh Miss Joseph
she's teaching and she says
um a president can't serve more than
eight years I said it's not true
and she's like uh what about that's
simply not true I said we have empirical
data that shows that you can actually I
said uh Linda banks Johnson took over as
president under November 22nd 1963. he
announced uh he of course ran in 64. he
chose not to run a 68. I said it's very
clear you could serve more than eight
years and so we argued back I said I'm
sorry you I said I know you think that
you you were right I said but it's right
here like what are you talking about and
so we had a test and I wouldn't and so I
wrote on the test and then she marked it
wrong I'm like oh look you're wrong and
so then we had this follow-up exam with
a follow-up quiz and I think I probably
had like a average of like 102 in this
class of extra credit and stuff and I
was like you know what I said I'm just
gonna Mark zero on my quiz
I said in protest and what is going to
drop my grade down to 101.5
and man she was like she was livid and I
said look I get it you don't want to be
wrong
but the facts are clear JFK assassinated
November 22nd LBJ becomes president he
runs in 64. he declines in 68 I said do
the math that's more than eight years
and so she was like upset and so that
that's the thing for me my hell deal is
that's why I hate when I even when I was
on CNN I hated when they would say
people someone would say something and
I'm like they lying
and they will stand there and they would
just you know roll them when's the last
time what was the last year you were
wrong
was it 80s was it nice if it's happened
then I'm just curious man it's been a
long time no because it made I mean I'm
seriously I'm talking about I am and if
I if I say something I said something
that was incorrect on on the air the
other day we came in from the break I
said living correct uh information I
gave you it's like boom because okay
here's the philosophy he's a philosophy
if you're driving down the street or if
you're watching yeah and somebody says
something and no one says anything yeah
yeah you go
that must be correct no one says
anything so what happens is especially
in cable news or even on Broadcast News
they will sit there and they will just
let people say stuff yeah and just slide
and I'm sitting there going
so
we just gonna sit here and just let that
lie just stand and then it's kind of
like okay now we have time no that was a
lie and then what they'll do is then I
hate this well we'll come back in fact
take the next day no no you fact check
in the moment but the problem is most of
these people who are television anchors
they are not smart they're not well read
and they have they rely on a producer to
have to fact check them provide them
facts whereas for me no we're gonna fact
check in real time like right right now
you say something yeah and my whole deal
is you're talking I'm sitting there on
my iPad I remember Michael Singleton was
we working with the uh Ben Carson
campaign he goes no rolling Ben Carson
has an HBCU plan I'm like no he doesn't
he's like I guarantee I'm like smart you
know what schmeichel
I said why don't you make your point and
I'm gonna sit over here and go to his
website so go ahead and finish your
point so he's talking I'm sitting there
I'm
I'm like are you done
um and I had this phrase Shelley was my
director I'll go and so anytime my
audience knew when I say Shelly go to my
iPad
somebody's but I'm about to get in
somebody's ass it's about to happen
right now and I went Shelly go to my
iPad
sure Michael this is his website
this is the search box
HBCU click
do you see any like it's on the screen
and he's sitting there it's like oh God
and I'm just and I'm killing them
and I'm like dude you I said and we we
just break our sister Michael
never ever go on the air and be emphatic
with something if you had not checked
before you said it
and to this day he's gotten other
television he thanks me because I put
him on TV first he said you taught me a
valuable lesson he said you handed my
ass to my said because you didn't fact
check before came out of your bottle
yeah I mean listen you see that happen
on a lot and you know I I'd love to see
a system where during elections so we
did this one debate one time where we
had this guy who was Pro uh uh she was
uh from a normal she was a director of
normal to legalize marijuana and the
other guy was a Navy intelligence guy
captain and they came and we were doing
this uh sit down five six years ago and
the way we did it which was fascinating
is every time a person gave a fact or a
statement with Rita the bottom would say
and then it would show red or it would
say green yes this is exactly what there
you go I would love a format that both
candidates Republican Democrat every
time they say something a fact check we
should have the technology for people to
be able to do that though but you don't
have to actually wait for them to say
yes or no to that right because you got
these debates you just do it no you just
do it yeah and and and so what do you
think CNN ABC Fox what do you think
these guys well because it's an inside
game it's an inside game well the game
is you like you like uh the invitation
you want to invite them back so you want
to make them happy and so you don't want
to take them off and so the show's like
oh no so we're so we're going to go soft
if you will as opposed to you know both
sides do that go hard right so you take
so September this September 21 I'm on
ABC news this week and Chris Christie
gave his big speech at the Reagan
Library you know we need to move on from
Trump whatever so we're sitting there
and so and again I'm just a guess right
okay I'm not a contributor the other
three people contributors George
Stephanopoulos is sitting right there
and so I'm like during the break they
said we can talk about Chris Christie's
speech and the uh forgot the sister she
uh she said you sure we'll talk about
that to George and she he goes yeah no
I'm I'm not saying anything inside I'm
like oh hell yes bring this speech up
please bring this speech up so it comes
up and so George talks and Chris is
talking and he's you know taking his
very high and mighty stance and I'm and
I'm sitting there and if you're like go
back and watch it I'm waiting because
see this is what I I teach people you
can't be too eager to jump in so you you
have to let it come to you so he talks
and they're talking back and forth and
then she talks and then she talks and
then George gets to me and I make my and
I turn to Chris Christie and I say you
have to accept the responsibility you
played in creating that man
and I and I just went right at him and
he's like you know I ran against him in
2016 but you debate prepped him in 2020
and you support he was I'm talking about
he turns red man to be fair I mean to be
fair like this is like uh uh the one
thing about politics it's you saw Kamala
calling out Biden yes immediately and
then boom she's the VP yes George H.W
bush called Reagan's economic policies
voodoo economics right yes but but again
though but you accept the fact that you
did it so remember he she was totally
fine right you know she called them out
she called them out and they became VP
my Pro my problem with Christy right was
you're giving this huge speech like he
was this problem of the problem and I'm
sitting there going yes but you created
the monster so it's so like you can't
complain about the monster when you
create when you help create the monster
when there was an option to say
I have convictions morals principles and
values I simply cannot stand with a
known liar right and what I say it is
you chose politics and power over
principles and patriotism happens on
both sides right all the time yeah I
never said it doesn't the point is you
have to be willing to actually say it so
when somebody so if you say okay I was
very much against this here now I'm for
it okay but in being if it blows up
don't try then don't try to come back
and go well I mean I knew everything was
going to blow up no no no no no no no
you didn't stand on principle and I
think that's that's that's a huge
problem today when we look at not just
politics but also business when we have
people I'm going back to the whole point
about when I was in the kindergarten if
you have to be willing to stand on truth
knowing
it's going to cost you
and when you when you can accept that
to me this is just me yeah I'm gonna
sleep a lot better because I'm simply
not going to just go along to get along
if I actually have conviction that this
person is not it I don't care what they
do and what they promise I can't stand
with you right not going to happen so so
okay so so that's good that you're
saying that because I I like stats I
like data okay to go through some data
and we'll cover some of that because I
truly want to get your opinion my ideal
situation would be to have a panel of of
folks from both sides to debate and have
a conversation together civilly I think
that's the way where the audience wins
uh where you're able to say here's what
I believe the other person says what I
believe and then there is the facts
meaning I got new twists for it there's
a not both sides what do you mean how
about you have a debate say again though
see this is this is where the it this is
because again I lived it see when it's
both sides
because when I say I lived it they would
speak the truth in The Green Room
but when they call in the air what
happens is their side their tribes are
watching so they defend the tribe versus
the issue so here's why I told CNN why
don't we have some debates where you
actually have two Republicans who
disagree on the issue that way you take
party out now becomes the issue the
problem today in most debates we're not
debating the issue we're debating the
sides when you debate the issue it's not
your Democrat your Republican you're
left you're right you're blue you're red
no no what's the issue and so when
people have said to me they're like I've
never self-identified as a Democrat or
Republican I refuse have I voted for
republicans and Democrats yes because I
look at what's this issue I'm a huge
school choice person yeah oh I've had
some Democrats who have who and I'm like
y'all want to swing let's swing and the
Republicans are going well man you stay
with us on this issue I'm like no I
don't stand with you in terms of the
party on the issue I stand with the
issue but gender that's the problem we
have today but we don't discuss the
issue well who do you think is more
united you think Democrats are more
united with each other they may disagree
behind closed doors but they're United
with each other we think Republicans are
more united above each other because
Republicans here's why the Democratic
tent is actually a Big Ten like you
literally have conservative Democrats
moderate Democrats you got Progressive
then you got far you got far left or a
Democrats you look at ain't that many
moderate Republicans to be true I'm
talking about they're basically
non-existent in Congress so you're
either right or far right so the
Republicans it's a lot easier when
they're debating issues because you you
cannot be in the liberal Republican uh
Senator um uh Edward Brooke the first
African-American electus is
reconstruction to the United States
Senate okay was a liberal Republic of
Massachusetts okay there is no way
today he could ever be elected not going
to happen in fact if you actually look
at Hell Ronald Reagan on a lot of stuff
on amnesty in December
it'll be a little hard for Reagan so
Republicans are a lot easier because
from an ideological standpoint is pretty
much right far right that's why in the
Democratic caucus when you look at when
these issues come up it's a lot harder
to bring them together to get the 218
yeah because you got these different you
got 20 over here yeah 10 over here you
got and so it's a lot harder so
absolutely Republicans okay so let's
let's do issues how about let's just go
on issues with yeah with today what
issues do you see Republicans presenting
that you agree with uh to specific
specific issue is to African Americans
that's the main topic I wonder what
questions do you see where Republicans
come over to say you know what I
actually like that idea and what do you
see the left coming of Democrats coming
up with it you're like more Republicans
are willing to support the idea of
school choice than Democrats because
your teachers unions are largely opposed
to the expansion of school choice and
they are a significant donor to the
Democratic party
the problem I have when I'm when I'm
standing with Republicans I then go but
why what's your motivation
in many cases is to destroy the unions
it ain't about the kids
so I've stood in front of folks and I
said okay same thing with the expansion
of about your program yeah
I will I go okay
do you who do y'all care about do you
care about the expansion of voucher
programs to truly help the kids who need
it who are in the worst schools or you
actually trying to help largely white
Suburban parents get extra money to
afford to go to private schools and
after that conferences to say that in
people's room like
damn this the keynote I'm like yes
because for me it's for those kids who
are actually in the worst schools so
even though we will agree on that policy
like I had a woman who called me from
Texas and she calls Dr Steve Perry so he
like I'm not from Texas but my boy
Roland is born and raised in Texas and
so we get on the phone and so she's like
we're trying to mobilize uh Black and
Hispanic parents you know around
expansion of vouchers program so she's
talking and Steve are to give me her
name and she's just talking talking and
I'm like
You're Gonna Lose
you like what I mean I said let me ask
you a question you you care about black
and Spanish kids on the issues like
absolutely I say why is your board all
white
I say in fact let me ask you this
question can you tell me the top 10
highest performing Black and Hispanic
LED charter schools in San Antonio
Houston Dallas take a pick
she got quiet
I said but you're calling me because you
want to mobilize Hispanic and black
parents on this issue to get this to get
uh this voucher Pro program pass and you
don't even know who the Black and Latino
top charter schools are
so how can you I said so you want their
voices but you don't even know them and
she just froze and again
I I froze her because again you're
proving to me that you're not you're not
legit on this now if you go if you go on
the Democratic side uh where where do I
stand uh with the Democrats absolutely
when it comes to the issue of voter
protection uh and voting in this country
um it is it is the Republican Playbook
voter suppression is no doubt the
closing of polling locations uh making
difficult I mean they've literally said
it publicly that I mean the Speaker of
the House in Georgia said if we expand
ballot drop boxes and allow folks to
vote
um uh absentee without an excuse we will
lose now my whole deal is how can you
walk around with troops and go oh
democracy and they're fighting for our
values and it's the right to vote no
every politician should want everybody
to vote
and you don't you don't create obstacles
that is the biggest one where I stand
against Republicans I don't I don't know
about that but you know what what I
would say you can break it down to
issues no but what I would say with that
too is to you know somebody can come
back and say well Roland how about the
fact that you know Democrats don't care
about the Border because the more people
come from the border they tend to vote
more for Democrats so it's better for
them to not talk about the board of any
well first first of all that assumes
that somebody who's crossing the border
uh is a registered voter when they're
not because here's a deal but but the
Democrats want them to be able to vote
and to say they also have a voice should
they be able to vote but the rally is
see now what you've done is you've now
flipped it to another issue which is the
Border what I'm talking about is what is
undeniable when it comes to the no I
don't flip it no I don't flip it no no
no no
I didn't flip it I didn't flip it I
asked the question from you what
policies on the right do you agree with
what policies on the left right then I
then you brought up voting to say that
the Republicans in Georgia want to do
this then I brought up the fact I didn't
bring up border I'm bringing border to
say that those people who come across
the border many times they're going to
vote left and they're going to vote
right but see that but that's actually a
wrong assumption because I'm from Texas
and we see what actually happens is what
you have is if you're talking about
you're saying people that come across
the border vote Republican what I'm
telling you is when you look at who is
who is coming across the border that's
fine I run an insurance company with 40
000 agents 54 Hispanic I lived in LA 24
years and here's the question no no no
but you said what you said you live in
L.A here's the fundamental problem that
people refuse to recognize when you talk
about Hispanics like Latinos in America
what percent is Hispanic no no first of
all follow me here follow me I know
exactly
no no it's not just the Texas side okay
the problem that we have in the country
when we break down Hispanics last
Latinos and the reason I'm saying
Hispanics last Latinos is because around
the country you can't group everybody in
the same category what you have is you
might have a different different uh
philosophy if you talk about Venezuelan
keeping in Florida compared to somebody
who is Chicano Florida
in Texas compared to Los Angeles and so
what you also have is a much different
uh Focus all you have to do is just look
up and see what percentage of Hispanic
vote Democrats can you pull it out no no
what I'm saying it's about six about 65
35 or some places 64. there you go but
here's the deal though if you
Republicans you liked at 35 what you
don't have for African Americans in the
case like black women who hates
Republican party the top two
constituencies for African-Americans
Democratic party are black women and
black men so you have so if you're if
you're running it's 35 40 percent it's a
damn good number oh stop it Roland this
is this this it's not you're getting 65
our vote 64 right there yes what are you
talking about and if and if and if you
are and if you are a Republican or the
Republican party yeah you also have to
ask yourself what have you done to reach
a community to get them to vote for you
Hispanics yes they're increasing on the
Republicans
increasing of course yes why is it
increasing why is it increasing I'm
asking you because the policies are
helping them out no it's increasing also
because you have a party that actually
is not taking any more proactive focus
in targeting that group if you never
communicate with me yeah or never reach
out to me guess what I'm gonna go with
who normally does and so that's the
smart strategy which is what I've
actually said the Republicans for the
long is if you never talk to black
people and they never see you guess what
they ain't gonna never vote for you by
the way I don't disagree with that I
think if you want someone's vote you got
to go talk to them and what they've done
is in the last 10 years yeah especially
in the last last eight years they've
actually made a much much more concerted
effort to Target Hispanics in the United
States do you think Democrats care about
blacks more than uh Republicans do
oh absolutely really I can't let me tell
you define define care for his for is
the first to find care I have to first
be willing to even talk to you
Republicans by and large they want to
avoid black people a group of black
Republicans in Illinois had a meeting
with the state Republican party yeah and
they they laid out hey there are ways
that we as a party can reach out to
African-Americans in Illinois in Chicago
they finished their presentation
this is the first statement that's made
guys look we're not going to support
welfare
the black Republicans win
um
who the hell brought out welfare
it wasn't even our proposal
the black Republicans were insulted at
this group of white Republicans
automatically went to welfare
and they said
we even bring up welfare
why is that the one thing you brought up
and so what community are you talking
about what where was this at say
Illinois okay and so what I'm saying is
which you're saying Illinois Democrats
have done good for blacks in Illinois no
that's not what that's not what your
question was the question was this here
in terms of who is reaching out to him
right I wanted when Mitch McConnell's
book came out right I'm on the Tom
Joyner Morning Show this is the largest
black Morning Show in the country before
he retired and we're sitting here and so
I get to call want to book a monkey no
problem then all of a sudden uh yeah uh
um yeah yeah Mitch [__] is not going to
come on the show
okay he's discussing his book why not
this is the largest show targeting
African-Americans I can tell you I've
had open invitations to Republicans come
on the show
When Alan West was in Congress I told
him about it Alan was like are you
serious Alan tells his press secretary
Alan would show up no no he was on the
show well not not always
um because I called him on live on air
one day uh I don't know if you're
respectful to him or not show up
anywhere no no Alan well yeah right well
not always but uh no we're with respect
he's a gamer But Not Afraid right but
not always
um
yeah he may have a schedule you're right
not all no no when I caught him live on
the air uh so
um so the Amazon and I tell him that
Alan goes are you serious I said yes I
said people open invitation I said to
the entire public in caucus and he goes
tells us secretary sent a note out to
the whole caucus it look you should come
on this show it's important
two in the recent other than Allen the
reason was two one uh was a republican
from Texas a Texas A M graduate that's
why it came on the other was Pete Olson
from Texas uh who came on as well
because out of Houston and so what
happens is they avoid in many ways
talking to African Americans you're I'm
never going to be able even to listen to
you
if you don't even talk to me
and if you ever talk to me and I'm and
I've had long conversations I've known
black Republicans my entire life the
frustration they have you go back to
Jackie Robinson and Nixon in 1960. the
frustration that they have is here they
are talking about black being black
conservative and being Republican and
the pushback and the hell they get from
their own I'm talking about we've had
like serious conversations and we're
talking about individuals who have been
cabinet secretaries who have been in
many layers who are millionaires who are
donors and they express how it drives
them crazy when they do it that was
Michael Williams who worked in Reagan
Bush breaking the Bush Administration
very good friend of mine he was gonna
have a fundraiser at his house uh and
there was a guy running for congress
against Martin Frost in Texas and he was
campaigning he brought JC Watson and
everything and at the time in these
black church burnings and so Michael
calls him up and Michael says hey
I think the candidate should release a
statement with regards to these Church
he's burning black churches and they go
no no we're not going to do that that's
best pandering
like I said I'm sorry wait man
which I brought
Congressman JC Watson and to tour with
you to black churches
on Sunday like what the hell you call
that so Michael's wife Donna Donna said
because they were fundraiser at Michael
and Donna's house Donna said
ain't no man
who's unwilling to speak against the
church burning of black churches welcome
in my house
you let them know no statement he will
not step foot in this house foreign
Republicans won't even talk so therefore
the only place the only place we can
talk to you is Democrats and that's one
reason why Republicans have largely lost
so that that is your uh okay so let's
say that's true no no it's not for you
it is I've been black for 54 years and I
have spent as I have run black owned
media Outlets
getting Republicans to even talk to
black people show up at forums my
parents work my parents were finals of a
Civic club I'm telling you not my
opinion what I've literally experienced
and what black Republicans and even what
I've had conversations about is when
white Republicans but I got a follow-up
for you so in other words in other words
Democrats are only ones that had the
votes of blacks since 1964 okay 88 was
64.64 and it's now 88 86 90 right yeah
so if blacks have had if if Democrats
have had that vote since 64 that's 60
years 59 years to be exact how come
blacks haven't made major progress if
Democrats care about blacks as much as
well first of all that's that's actually
flawed question because when you say
having major what kind of progress
so when you look at what you're coming
out of 1960s then you go in the 1970s
when you begin to see your first wave of
black Mayors across the country mayor
and Berry in D.C Maynard Jackson Atlanta
Coleman Young in Detroit uh of course
previously you had Gary Hatcher in Gary
Indiana what you saw for the first time
was African-Americans being able to
access economic a capital in this
country Maynard Jackson gets elected in
73 African-Americans were receiving
point zero zero one two percent of All
City contracts in Atlanta I didn't say
one percent I didn't say point five
percent I didn't say point one two they
were
.0012 of All City contracts Maynard
Jackson comes in he says ain't gonna
happen not when you have a city that the
significant number of African-Americans
the reason Atlanta is called the black
Mecca today because economically uh
you're part of that particular process
when you talk about Prince George's
County being called today uh the richest
cap black County in the country based
upon home values a lot of that is
because of again Contracting
opportunities that came with Miriam
Barry uh was mayor and then coming out
of that now what you have when you're
talking about uh the black community
when you're looking at overall you have
to look at the fact of the matter is
this here African-Americans have been
technically fully free Americans for
only 53 years
64 Civil Rights Act 65 Voting Rights Act
68 Fair Housing Act and you steal we're
dealing with
um being locked out when you when you
look at and look it comes the money if
you're not having a money conversation
in America you ain't having a real
conversation and so when you talk about
400 plus years and you're only being
technically free 53 years and you've
been locked out consistently out of
corporate America I have actually met
nipples which is sad individuals who
were the first African-Americans to ever
work at major companies and they got
there in 72 73 75 78 you're like what
the heck so when you've been locked out
economically yeah which has an impact on
every single Factor place in America
housing health education then you see
why where we are today but has there
been progress yes has there been enough
progress no Roland so so if I can finish
my question yep okay I'll give you I'll
let you go but you got finish my quest
go ahead okay
so if uh we have a leadership team
running an insurance company
for five years and the company isn't
growing
you're going to sit there and say okay
cool you know hey you know what you guys
don't go talk to the employees we do
great that doesn't mean you're good to
employees that just means you're going
out there to talk to the employees and
brag about the fact that you're talking
to the employees let's give them five
more years
let's give them 10 more years let's give
them 20 more years let's give him 53
years fast forward today if he can pull
up this article you're a data guy
27 of the top 30 crime-written cities in
America ran by democrats yep if
if they are all about blacks why are
their policies ruining great communities
question for you pull it back up yeah
what's the root cause of it what is it
I'm asking you no no you raise it up no
no no you said 27 the top 30 crime no no
no no no no no here's the deal though
if you're going to ask a question what I
need you to do is I need you to then go
okay what actually looking at those
communities what created what actually
happened in those areas
you brought up Chicago lived there six
years what is it
you tell us no no no see here's the deal
though this is this is the time
statistics
this is 27 out of 30. would you like you
like stats I'm giving you stats but
nothing about what I said is not a fact
I'll read it but here's the film as of
June 22nd right okay go to the top I'll
read the entire article for you yeah
that's what you're asking me no that's
not what I'm asking a new report shows
that Democrat policies on cities and
counties are responsible for Rising
crime rates in their otherwise red
States what are the policies they're the
the Heritage Foundation today whatever
whatever the policies are is democratic
policy no no no no border policies
whatever the policies are whatever I
don't need to know the problem yes you
do no I do not I don't even know I don't
need to know the policies all I need to
know is if you say Democratic policies
but what other policies but wait a
minute if I give you and I vote for you
and you're supposed to take care of me
why are 27 out of top 30 cities in
American Crime ran by democrats okay
first I will tell you first of all it's
where African-Americans are living so
let's bring up Chicago in particular
what you have had in Chicago is you have
had some of the most the greatest racial
segregation not in 20 years not in 30
years but literally in 100 plus years no
no here's the deal though okay I will
show you how Mississippi has the largest
percentage of black people in America
run by Republicans broke as hell explain
that explain me the highest the highest
tell me when you have no hold up
stay on topic hold on wait wait wait
wait hold on let's stay on topic is
crime 27 out of 30. not economic
economic is a different story no it's
not but I agree with you that we need to
get the financial situation no no no no
and you're making this one in
Mississippi no you're making them no
here's the mistake you make 27 out of
three mistake you're making when you say
crime I just I just obliterated a black
black conservative my show on this whole
issue when you say crime you have to
then say okay what is the what is the uh
the the what creates crime no what what
creates crime what creates crime
when people are not doing well
financially what else
your surrounding an environment who
you're around nobody else pick up habits
what else bad policies no no no what
else see you know see you're jumping the
policies
wait a minute
if I run a comp if I run a company and
I'm the CEO of the company if the
company improves or doesn't improve is
based on my policies I'm the head
running the company the department if it
doesn't improve it's because of me so
let me so let me lay it out to you again
go forward when you talk about what is
the underpin what the underpinning of
crime
John hope Bryan founder of operation
hope this is what he said he said show
me a community where you've seen a riot
with a credit score of 700 or higher the
reality is when you talk about crime in
this country you're talking about
economics you're talking about education
you're talking about housing you're
talking about health show me areas where
you do not have high crime I am going to
show you areas that don't have the same
uh uh aren't as compacted that's first
what you have is when you talk about
crime in places you then look at what
are the numbers of people there what are
the pockets there what are those
communities and how did those
communities how would they create it
literally not over 20 30 years but
literally over 50 75 100 years now
that's that was Jim Crow how many years
does it take to change what are you
talking about how many years does it
take okay when you have when you have
how long does it no no create change
when you first of all you're talking
about a black in a
when you have had when you have had yeah
okay walk through 243 Years of Slavery
92 years of Jim Crow and then you get to
1970 when you are technically fully free
you can't act like all of that before
they're not they're not impact the issue
that you're having now
have to do with not Democratic or
republican policies it has to do with
literally white supremacy and Jim Crow
in America we are still to act as if we
are still not dealing with that how did
how how did housing discrimination take
place in this country do you know who
created it the Realtors
they apologize for it why are you what
going away from the question no no
because here's the deal though you don't
want to deal with what create brother
crime crime area you got to realize this
listen I'm dealing with the real truth
how how they create it what you're
dealing with is oh there are democratic
areas what I'm dealing with is how well
how do you deal with the historical
reality of neighborhoods that simply
can't be just oh we elected one person
and that it's going to change it doesn't
work that way I'm Middle Eastern okay I
was born in Iran ten years my mother's a
communist my dad's an imperialist okay
Escape we go to Germany I lived at a
refugee camp for two years okay with
people who are Yugoslavian Czech
Albanian at the time and they're all
leaving for a reason I come to the
states okay I'm a welfare baby I'm a
food stamp baby okay just letting you
know my parents are divorced twice in 20
years I'm going to Glendale High School
I have a lunch ticket it I would sell
because I don't have any money I'm six
one 130 pounds I should tell you the
fact that we don't come from a lot of
money one day I'm in the school and my
teacher starts talking about politics up
until that point when I think about
politics all I think about is divorce
because I think about my mom and dad
arguing all the time I don't have a lot
of pain linked to politics at the time
and the teachers to obviously the
teacher is going to be a Democrat
because she's presenting how rich people
are disciplined okay great which people
are bad so I love it obviously thirteen
to one that's the number that's dude I
had a whole lot of them Republicans like
teachers in my life why I like stats and
the stats are 13 to 1 as Democrats to
Republican you know the stats okay I
come home and I say Mom are we
Republicans Or democrats
and she said we're Democrats I said tell
me why
she says because the Democrats are for
the poor Republicans are for the rich so
my my mom says you know what I told her
I said when I grow up I want to be
Republican
not because I want to be a republican I
don't know what the policies are so
first of all what she was who's actually
for the rich and the poor who who was
for the rich and the poor she said she
said Republicans for the rich because of
the poor is that you say you love is it
wasn't true enough first of all was it
true or not whether that's true
statistically more rich people on the
Democratic side today no no no no no no
you say who are for not who's rich but
but who are they for the power but
Roland this is you you're smart
I understand but you're a smart guy bro
listen when I watch you you're not a
dummy you're very smart Okay so
sometimes John Maxwell said something
very important very important that that
I completely held to myself and every
time I break this I don't like it he
said the moment you learn sales and you
learn persuasion okay the moment you
learn the ability how to persuade you me
we learn how to persuade he says be very
careful to not go one step above that
which is to manipulate just to win all
arguments because you can you can win
any argument if you want to you can play
Devil's Advocate and play up the
argument play the Republican side and
you'll make one hell of an argument to
be the Democrat because you can do that
you have the ability to have the ability
as well I don't want to do that what I'm
asking you right now is the following
results today yes 27 out of 30 cities
yes that are ran by democrats are the
highest crime in America that's that
what state to live in which what are
those States the states are different
than the community New York Chicago but
that's not the thing the state is the
community the city is where what are you
talking about the city you're in is what
you can touch every year you come up and
you say re-elect me I can help state
listen I am born and raised in Texas
Houston
Clinton Park
act as if what no oh no
because they can't do anything first of
all I didn't say that let me let me
finish my thought
I am born and raised in Houston Texas
grew up in Clinton Park neighborhood to
act as if what happens in Austin does
not have an impact on Houston it's crazy
you're making excuses now no I'm not
you're making excuses okay here's the
deal though here's the deal though see
it's real easy to say it's excuses when
I'm stating facts and the point I'm
stating is that's not a fact that's just
an opinion no it's a fact the state of
Texas significantly has an impact
economically educationally on what
happens in Houston that's a fact yeah
but somebody as somebody or somebody who
as a kid travels with my mom to rallies
and events with the Metropolitan
organization in the state capital I
understand you grow up rich who did you
grow up no my parents didn't go to
college how are you rich then what do
you mean how how are you rich here's how
because here's how yeah because first
and foremost
the neighborhood that I grew up in had
it was one of the first master plan
communities by Hood what you had in my
neighborhood was you had folks first of
all I had Mom and Dad one who also
married also hell yeah they're still
married 56 years
um who who absolutely believed in
education now what I recognize is so for
me in my household yeah what my parents
emphasized never went to college then my
brother went to Texas A M I went to
Texas A M my sister went to then Texas A
M and so that was our house what I
recognize is that somebody who is next
door or across the street around the
corner did not have the situation that I
had now I totally get that what I don't
do is be arrogant enough to say well I
did this why can't you because I
understand that not everyone has the
exact same setup the same situation what
I'm talking about and this is the again
but but why not give that story of
inspiration to say you can get out of it
first of all you say why not why I'm
sorry hey you clear I've never watched
my show when what I talk about
consistently are these very issues I
don't see it here and go do Doom and
Gloom every single ever first of all
every single Tuesday on my show I
feature actual black owned businesses
every single Wednesday I feature
African-Americans who are tech companies
I love that every Friday I actually
feature something called education
matters of folks who are in the
education space school choice I got HBCU
connect so I do all of that sugar so
first so so what was second one second
but you know why I said that let me tell
you why I said that because you said
because you said I'm not the one that
says look at me I got out so can you
that's what you said no no no no no no
no no no here's why I say that because
it is air it is arrogant
when as an individual I'm one assuming
everyone else situation is the same
that's first two it's also arrogant to
then not actually study and look at how
from a macro level see you're describing
a micro level there's always you can
always have uh that singular individual
or this person or that person or this
family that's micro what I'm talking
about is macro issues and what I'm
saying is when I look at communities
that's that micro that's macro even
within the African-American Community
when you when you dealt with Jim Crow
you couldn't live anywhere else you
literally could not live anywhere else
bottom line is if you were black and had
money and then you were black and broke
you were literally living in the same
neighborhood after gym after Jim Crow
ends with integration what then happened
those African-Americans who were middle
class of a middle class began to move
away what then began to happen was you
had areas where poverty increased even
more so why move away because if you
care about the community why not stay
there and change it well first of all
does anybody else move what do you mean
who the hell else don't move how do you
think suburbs were pretty oh wait a
minute what do you mean how do you think
white flight was created but so it so
everybody else but we can't move but if
you act like you care about the
community
no but I'll answer your question do you
know why because when African-Americans
are living in black neighborhoods they
also had economically embraced depressed
housing values and the reality is they
were not able to help change it are you
serious yeah I am
are you familiar with Palmdale I'm gonna
need you to be drug tested
seriously yeah do you even know today
we've done the stories in Florida when
somebody's black selling their house the
appraisers will come in and literally
give them a value a hundred to three
hundred thousand dollars less because
they're black
you know that that's actually happened
right you'll take one story and say that
oh my God on how many occasions has that
happened that are you serious do you
think a message like okay why don't you
go ahead and Google why don't you go
ahead and go how many times
the New York Times literally just did a
story talking about these systemic
racism that exists within housing
appraisals this is a fundamental problem
I'm trying to see you're living in a
different reality what what progress are
you making by saying that so progress so
what you're doing to end that
okay do you know how in hair okay hold
on you say you're Middle Eastern right
you're trying to hold on you said your
middle eastern yes how would you feel
how would you feel yes if you're selling
your home you've got a home that you
know right and you put upgrades in it
and you know your home is worth 500 000
yes
somebody comes into your home and they
see your photos right and they see your
family and then they go back and they go
350 000. you go what the hell
one second one second
it's actually out of a thousand
appraisers out of a thousand appraisals
how many times does that happen out of a
thousand appraisals how many times does
that happen you want to pull that up
out of a thousand appraisals how many
times does that happen let's just say it
happens it is a significant issue in
America oh my God wait for one second
one second and then when the woman takes
when the woman a black person should not
have to remove their photos from the
wall and remove black art and remove
black books to have a white appraisal
then come in and go oh it's actually 550
so one sec one second because I'm gonna
show you how it impacts generationally
here we go so when you follow me here
because this this is housing experience
when you then get that lower appraisal
you then right cannot sell your house
for the higher value which then means
you are not then taking those proceeds
and being able to invest being able to
send your kids to school and what I'm
trying to explain to you is there is a
world out here that for some reason
you're like living in unity world that
ain't the real America
rid of that stuff you have the wrong guy
here you have to I'm trying to get rid
of it okay good for you me and I am as
well but you have the wrong guy here and
here's what I mean by that so when you
ask the question what do you do if they
praise your house 350 000 less right
that's your question okay I don't see
myself as a victim I stop looking at
myself as a victim a long time ago and
by the way being Armenian and Assyrian
you know what a lot of people in The
Armenian Community do you know what a
lot of people in The Armenian Community
do they sell victimhood mentality I'm
raised with that which is the statement
of Mecca I know you don't know what the
word merca means
oh poor rolling oh poor pbd I don't see
myself as a victim and the other part is
when you use one story as an example to
divide and get people even angrier
because out of a thousand appraisals
this happened one time I don't think
you're unified when you say statement
like that to say hey this is what's
taking place all the time but going back
to it so you'll left because you wanted
better economic situation for yourself
this is listen to what you just said
again I'm having to listen to it when
you're saying it's so fundamentally
flawed because when you say oh my God
you see yourself as a victim you do no
no you're selling it no I'm not what I'm
selling is a reality what I'm selling is
when the this is again since you didn't
I guess you couldn't pull it up okay oh
he did okay the body Administration the
federal Housing Finance Agency released
47 million appraisal reports to the
public For the First Time The appraisals
which were compiled between 2013 and
2021 present evidence of a persistent
widespread practice in the home
appraisal industry to give higher values
to homes when the occupants are white
and devalue them if the owners are
people of color such [__] that's
such [__] you know why hold up wait
let me tell you about that they actually
took the reports and showed the data and
now you call it [__] of course so
you so you asked for the data in the
fact
okay so when you run a company how much
[__] can I find in the Opex
how many what with Opex when I go into
my balance sheet and I look at my
expenses my monthly expenses what I'm
paying for yeah rent employees benefits
workers comp I can give a number and say
we lost 280 000 this year
and it's like oh my God we lost 280 000
and then I opened up the balance sheet
and then boom I'll see you you're moving
your face like you know what I'm talking
about first of all when I get data like
this tell me the whole story to jump to
conclusion with something like this what
I've seen the entire story is ludicrous
to make a comment like that but
analyzing the millions of appraisals by
using census break it down for as a
proxy for neighborhoods and comparing
communities with nearly identical
housing stock yeah two researchers found
that the results showed a clear
correlation the higher the proportion of
white residents in each Community the
higher the appraised value of individual
homes they compared similar data see
again you want to reject the facts and
what I'm trying to explain to you is I
am not I am refusing to wow constantly
have people give data without me having
access to the entire thing oh just for
their own benefit to the device so what
you're saying is in in order for you you
need access to the 47 million home
appraisals I'd love this for yourself I
would love to see it okay guess what
it's a federal agency
here's follow what a foia okay so I'd
love to see it you know why here here's
the part how often do you see data being
used and we don't know the whole story
both sides
how often but first of all we see data
out there but what I'm saying I'm
looking at
data actual data and I'm also looking at
a reality and here's what I'm saying to
you and again this is what you for some
reason you're not fully accepting when
what is the the most consistent way
Americans have been able to actually
build wealth it has been through housing
that's been historical and when you are
black in America this is not a opinion
this is not a perspective it's a fact
what we have seen is when you have been
unable to enter the Housing Industry
meaning covenants saying you can't sell
a black people then when you actually
buy a home and they've been grossly
undervalued that then limits you for
being able to sell your home at a higher
value and now take the profits and then
create a business and then be able to
send your kids to college and what I'm
saying to you is when that has been
persistent when you look at the
appraisals one when you look at
inability where you're buying a house
two all of a sudden now you see a clear
way how African-Americans have been
impacted now historically but still in
present day and what I'm saying to you
is whether you are democrat or
republican I want that to change because
what I want is somebody if you've had 53
years the Democrat when Republicans were
president Democrats and in charge they
didn't change wait a minute Democrats
have been Democrats have had the black
vote for 53 years what have you done
you're not even answering the question
what's that on this issue right one year
this issue right here is democratic
Republican independent it is a systemic
American problem you still haven't
answered my best question about 27 out
of 30 cities you blame the state no no
no I answer the question what did you
say I said to you yeah you show me high
crime areas I am explaining you how
there are high crime areas and what I'm
saying none of it has to do with their
policies
the what high crime cities in America
none of it has to do with Democrats
right and you can't even name the policy
what policy give me three Democratic
policies the point is you can name the
policies how much is your world it's
right if I'm if I'm in the business
world and you ask me a question that
ending cash bail uh defunding police
which is in our faces refusing to
prosecute categories of crimes uh
letting thousands of convicted felons
out on prison release uh prison
population so that's so that right there
that's the reason for a high that's the
reason for high crime in the last 20
years no I'm just saying that's that's
the article from was that from New York
Times you still have an answer no no no
no I'm actually answering yeah and
here's the whole deal first of all when
you talk about the issue of ending cash
bail that's actually been very recent
two ain't no defund the police the
reality is you have seen a major
increase in funding of police
years ago that's a flat out lie that
word that with a straight look on
yourself tell you right now I have
actually talked Direct so who who came
up with deep under police who came out
with the activists did active and
activists were Republicans Or democrats
they were activists first of all they
hate both parties you won't even talk to
them but I do but the Democrats in
Congress were repeating it no no no no
no no no no no no no no stop stop stop
AOC who else you said the Democrats in
Congress how many Democrats in Congress
oppose defund the police a lot but I'm
saying there were so some Inc
conversations
hell I could quote Louis goldmert and
some crazy stuff that he says and go
well you know what that's Republicans
the reality is this here Democrats
Democratic Mayors Democratic Governors
and yes Democratic president have
greatly increased funding of police in
this country ain't even a question
so we can you can holler but Democrats
defund the police when it shows they've
actually increased the show the video
they've increased them you asked for it
you asked for it show the video which
video now
show the video I just emailed you I just
text it to you because
Charles Barkley Democrats haven't said
they found the police at all because
they would never say that no you said
Democrats haven't said that activist
said that your word no no you said who
created the phrase I said it was who
said who supported that created who came
up with the concept of defunding the
police activists did day and then which
credible Democrats that were some
Democrats no not some no these are some
heavy duties no no no make it bigger
when Democrats control Congress how many
votes they had there you go when
Democrats control Congress Nancy Pelosi
when Democrats control Congress how many
votes they have
how much do they have what's your point
the point
223 Democrats vote to defund the police
health issues or policing in schools and
all the rest that perhaps we can uh
Shuffle some of that money around suck
it up be funding the police has to
happen we need to one of the policeman
Eric car said he's saying take some of
the money from policing about 150
million dollars I applaud Eric Garcetti
for doing what he's done
no no
[Music]
no it's not the allocation of resources
no you're wrong you're wrong do you do
you understand do you understand that in
a significant number of cities in this
country right where you have policing
who do everything okay you have in some
cities where the police are handing out
parking tickets where the police are
doing duties that they had nothing to do
with the streets when you say reallocate
what that says is okay why should we
have police handing out parking tickets
why don't we have them doing the major
function of fighting crime why don't we
actually have this unit that handles
that that's called reallocation when you
talk about the issue of mental illness
no I'm not I'm standing fast first of
all it makes me both of you a question
if either one of you actually covered
City Hall before
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no I'm giving you
don't you want facts here's the deal I
actually have been a city hall reporter
I have actually been in the city
meetings when you talk about why don't
you just say you were wrong
Democrats were wrong because I'm not
wrong because you're wrong no but but
wait a minute explain to me reallocation
hold up Mr CEO yeah when you're in a
company and when you reallocate funds
from one unit to the other are you
cutting funding or are you simply
adjusting why do you have a hard time
just saying they said it why do you have
a hard time by the way I can actually
count allow three people
if you allowed it you would have heard
them saying defund the police who I
literally wait a minute I literally
heard Nashville State Shuffle I heard
Kamala Harris say reallocate you go oh
that's defund you actually have a
reallocation of resources that exist in
city government County government state
government federal government every
single day but for some reason you don't
want to deal with that was it spin when
I told you that Democratic Mayors and
governors and the president they've
greatly increased police funding while
hold up can you acknowledge that as a
fact
if I sit with you and you can
acknowledge can you acknowledge the fact
and you can acknowledge that your side
of the Party Support it see this right
there see you're yelling your side I'm
not yelling my side independent here's
the whole deal though I first of all
again first of all in Texas you I don't
have to register as anything you you
still you still are not going to
acknowledge the fact that the defund the
police concept was brought up by acting
constantly reaffirmed by some of the
most powerful Democrats in America the
Speaker of the House saying in America
shuffling of funds that is not defunding
if you if you would the vice president
Kamala Harris said reallocation that is
not but ilhan Omar said not only defund
you said dismantle
um
that's one member of Congress right oh
but you want to let you know there's a
seven minute video
first of all show me here's the deal
show me 218 who defended that and
actually voted for it to happen please
you can't you know why stop because they
see this is this is where credibility is
lost we're talking about credibility is
lost if this is utterly hilarious I am
stating I understand Democratic mayors
Democratic Governors Democratic
president your voice doesn't validate
your argument increased funding mayor
Lori Lightfoot of Chicago to
20 million to the police department to
deal with the mental issues that they
were having oh I'm sorry is that
reallocation maybe one of the worst
places
money and reallocate it for that oh but
reallocation works when you agree with
it what I'm trying to explain to you is
when you say deep [__] cut you can
you can see fun means do you remember
earlier when I said there's a difference
between persuasion and manipulation you
can spin any argument you're very good
at debating you're very good at raising
your voice interrupting all that stuff
I've watched you for years I think it's
hilarious but what that both of you will
say that the Democratic party yeah has
supported defund the police when the
support when the fact that I had the
Democratic party came up with the idea
and you're wrong and they supported it
you're actually not heard Republicans
say defund the police you've not heard
actually you're actually wrong incentive
Tim Scott's policing bill that he
released in 2021 in the bill I will
happily send it to you what did he say
he actually said what did he say I want
to hear it no I'm gonna read hold on let
me guess he said reallocate no no no no
no no no no no no no no that's not what
he said
because see what you don't understand is
but here's what no no no when the drug
flawed Justice added the entire on the
George floor just as like the entire I
literally said this I sent this to
Senator Tim Scott and he didn't answer
my question when we were running for
office and I answered yes to that
question we are going to reduce funding
in the police department and redirected
growing and growing and growing
what did they do
we propose Cuts is a good thing
you don't know what she did in San
Francisco that wasn't a sheet that was a
guy a million yeah
no more police singing all these cuts
are a good thing in these communities if
they're not doing a job
right here no no no you say to me you
said oh show me Republican when Senator
Tim Scott introduced his bill
okay on police reform this is one of the
things that he did when it failed last
year he went on Margaret Brennan's show
CBS Face the Nation he said the
Democrats wanted to defund the police
and that was a bridge too far in Senator
Tim Scott's own bill they actually said
in order for police to qualify for these
funds laws would have to be passed on
the city of the state level
excuse me excuse me excuse me excuse me
oh my God so you buy that into defund
the police
you don't even listen buddy if there's
anybody who doesn't listen you listen
Senator Tim Scott said that they won't
get the funds if laws don't get passed
I'm telling you what he did he did a
year later calls that same thing respect
defund the police and I literally and if
you want to see it
those are the text messages you're so
funny I sent to Senator Tim Scott and I
said Senator Tim Scott please explain to
me the difference between what you said
the Democrats are doing what you did you
just hurt your argument even more
talking about because what you just did
is validated everybody else what they
just said no yes this is what Kamala
said what Nancy Pelosi said they're all
saying the same thing they've won the
police what is and now they realized it
was a bad idea did not say they found
the police of course he did not either
oh oh wait a minute so you say what
accomplish said was this your argument
you just threw yourself up no I didn't
you did no I didn't of course you did no
I was specifically calling out Senator
Tim Scott by trying to call something
defund the police when they were simply
proposing exactly you know what he you
know what's the problem here's the
problem Roland the problem is when when
I sat down when I sit down with somebody
with whatever thing they believe in okay
it's
specifically a lot on the Democratic
side ah it's specifically it is it is
being a Democrat before their country it
is how they vote before America it is
nope I'm gonna defend this because
there's no way there's these guys gonna
say anything wrong with defund the
police and and that's when you lose
credibility all you have to say is you
have nothing
or you that's all you have to say you
have no credibility on this when you
can't even acknowledge what reallocation
means you have no credibility when you
can't even Define that when I have
actually talked to Mayors and city
council members and they have walked
through how when London Bridge when the
policies
destroy the city first Democrats have
had to vote when the mayor when the
mayor of San Francisco talked about the
mental illness crisis in their
particular City and they said we need to
be sending mental health folks out on
calls and not always the cops now we've
seen numerous examples where that
happens what has actually happened in
the last 30 or 40 years in Democrat and
Republican cities and states in the
country we've seen a massive cut of
mental illness what is the greatest
increase
I'm stating facts but you don't like no
but you refuse to acknowledge knowledge
or accept because you're stuck on
Democrats ahead of 53 years you acted
I'm asking no no you act as if in those
53 years Republicans have never had
power you actually say Republicans have
never had the house or the senate or the
white house so here's the question I
said to you show me how the Republicans
there's no way to talk with you bro I
gotta tell you so show me how
Republicans changed so here's what I
think give me examples are you gonna let
anybody speak I'm I'm waiting for your
example if you have 92 of an entire
community's vote like the evangelicals
for 60 years that's evangelicals
evangelicals are also part of that black
vote if you have 90 if you have 92
actually don't understand Evangelical
black evangelism if you have 92 percent
of the black vote for 59 years
59 years later 27 out of 30 cities
for crime
are ran by democrats
your policies don't work and imagine
people have to revisit I'm gonna do it
let me finish and I'll let you talk you
either have to consider new policies or
the voters have to consider a new party
and let me ask you this question
when Republicans have been in charge of
the house
the Senate the White House or the
governor's mansion or State Rep and
state senators or the legislature
because 31 States right now they control
both Chambers a significant number of
them in the South where the majority of
black people are please show me
show me empirical data how the lives of
black people have fundamentally changed
on the Republican rule I'll wait do do
you know who started getting more votes
from the black community do you know who
your favorite guy
Republicans control all three branches
in South Carolina yeah they control
Georgia they control Mississippi they
control Arkansas they control Tennessee
so they control the legislature in North
Carolina so let me so since you do you
I'm gonna use your argument please show
me please please show me how
at the live African Americans are
drastically improved in those places
where Republicans completely control
than other places
show me
give me an example
Roland if you would have answered any of
my questions oh my God if you would
answer any of my questions
you don't like the answer no it's not I
don't like the answer you like the
answer you you say tell me the policies
I'm asking you the policies oh so so you
know so I can't ask you a question you
can but I would like I brought you here
invite me on your show and I'll give you
the answer no because I'm the guest wait
wait I brought you on the show first of
all you know my show if somebody asked
me a question hell I answer the question
I've answered your questions you still
can't answer it and the reason why you
can't answer it's been an hour and 20
minutes you can't still haven't answered
the question I have you have not
actually I have what policy here's why
you haven't answered you blame the state
no no you blame surrounding cities no
you blame Republicans that's what you
blame no no and I and I told you stating
for 59 years and first of all systemic
racism is a policy because it's actually
ingrained in our system that's first
what I'm also saying to you is what I
recognize is how do we fix these again
institutions how do we fix them first
first and foremost first and foremost we
gotta stop denying that actually it's a
problem which you have done oh no first
I just showed you it's a problem 27 out
of 30. it is a problem you've got to
stop it's a big problem 59 years
Democrats have had to vote and denied
the systemic reality of racism in the
housing appraisal industry by going I
need to see the 47 million you just
denied it and one million percent I need
to see the data and I want one million
percentage here's the deal and by the
way you're giving a little too much
credibility to New York Times here's the
deal oh okay fine yeah do you want to
pull up what first of all you gave it a
Heritage report
you read a New York Times report citing
a Heritage Foundation dude really wait
you're telling me New York Times got a
lot of credibility that's what you're
saying no I just told you you referenced
the Heritage Foundation dude come on
that's the daily signal that's the daily
signal who owns them I don't even know
who owns daily signal here at his
foundation okay great I've done their
show so that's an in-house organization
here's what I tell by the way go to it
go to another side to give 27 out of 30.
I'm going back I'm going back but you
still won't even answer and this is what
I'm telling you
you can't even show me now I'm gonna use
Mississippi since Mississippi has the
highest concentration of black people of
any state in America
the Republicans have ruled that state
since the Mississippi constitutional
convention in 1891 not a single
African-American has been elected
Statewide in Mississippi so if
Republicans control the governor's
mansion the hot the legislature in
Mississippi
how then since you talk about the
policies how is it the lives of African
Americans have not improved in
Mississippi if you say is if the
Democrats is their policies show me tell
me how it hasn't improved in Mississippi
uh Roland until you give me your answers
on the questions I've asked I gave you
that you're gonna go you don't want
specific example no and this is what I
will tell you Mississippi here's what I
will tell you Arkansas Tennessee South
Carolina North Carolina Georgia I've
given you multiple States you still
haven't answered the question I answered
your question no you have not you don't
like the ends no you have not answered a
question you blamed and deflected you
don't like the answers what is the
answer you don't like the answer what's
the answer your answer is tell me about
Memphis it's deflect that's a deflection
it's the first one I never even brought
up Memphis not Memphis Mississippi
Mississippi no I'm giving you an example
of what no because it's you you have an
extra money
let me say it again 59 years you've had
to vote you say and I'm telling you what
have you done about it you say it since
you said yeah since you said oh my God
you Democratic votes show me in
Republican red as reading States how
they have improved the lives of African
Americans
show me Roland Roland I don't think you
understand what I'm saying to you right
now I understand let me let me ask a
question for you what is your method of
helping black African Americans go ahead
tell us first and foremost when we talk
about helping African-Americans I'm
going to acknowledge what a systemic and
what is systemic
systemic yeah defined systemic is when
you have the housing appraisal that's
systemic okay okay systemic is when you
have a higher proportion four to five
times of black children who are being
expelled or arrested in school compared
to White's kids that's systemic now no
no no no no you asked how first and
foremost we have what's Community we
have what's systemic what's Community
Based which means the village or also
what is individual when you start
talking about how do you make
transformations in this country first
and foremost you have to deal with the
two most important things health and you
deal with the issue of Education when
Republicans and conservatives were
talking about get rid of Roe v Wade I
literally say it okay gotcha and I had I
had been Watson the former NFL player
come on he did a documentary on the
issue of abortion and I said Ben here's
the fundamental problem when I hear
pro-life I said they're not pro-life
the anti-abortion
I said because the people who are
so-called pro-life I said show me the
policies when they confront the infant
mortality rate among African-Americans
show me when they confront the higher
number of black women who are dying in
childbirth people who are having
children he said you can't
they literally can't and so that's a
that's an example when you talk about
again Health we're talking about uh a
prenatal care we talk about those issues
that means that if you're a black child
and you have a higher incident of black
women who are dying in childbirth Serena
Williams see it ain't just money thing
Serena Williams talked about all her
money how she almost died in childbirth
because white doctors were not listening
to her do you know the opioid crisis why
it initially was killing more white
people
you know why tell us because doctors in
America
the study showed it doctors were saying
we're not going to prescribe the opioids
to African-Americans because we think
they're coming to us for drugs so y'all
gotta take Tylenol so they were over
prescribing Oxycontin and all these
powerful meds and I said well my
goodness thank God the one-time racism
benefited black people we were not over
prescribed uh uh uh Oxycontin and other
bills of appeals the white death rate
has the the average average length of
whites Living in America has dropped
largely because of the opioid crisis
what I'm so that's systemic that is
systemic in your system how do we fix
the sex so but first of all the way you
first of all fix anything systemic you
even acknowledge that it's systemic
that's first two then you have to have
your data and then being go in and say
okay now let's now confront the reality
what we're facing you cannot have in
schools where you have largely white
teachers
who don't know how to handle black kids
whose automatic call is call the cops
where you now have kids who are in
kindergarten first grade who now are
being handcuffed and now taken down to
jail what you have to deal with is in a
school system how do you deal with those
children but also where they're coming
from what's one of the issues I thought
the numerous superintendents and
teachers one of the biggest things that
kids are coming to school hungry
when Republicans when you talk about
folks you talk about food it's about
porn
when they wanted to cut SNAP benefits I
was sitting here going
to explain that to me how we got the
richest prosperous country in the world
and we want to cut food benefits to folk
who are hungry
kids teachers principals superintendents
have said one of the biggest things that
we're facing are kids who literally are
coming to school who are hungry that's
why they can't study probably got
discipline problems so now okay
this down how do we deal with that we
have to acknowledge that even exists
what we can't do is from a macro
political levels go oh oh these folks
y'all just don't want to work it's
called The Working Poor for a reason
they are working
I'm not gonna just throw people under
the bus and go oh you're just you're
just ignorant you don't want to work I'm
acknowledging the fact of the matter is
when the Republican governor of Alabama
not 10 years ago he wanted to change the
tax code
and he used Jesus as the model he said
folks in Alabama they were taxing the PO
they were taxing people beginning at 4
600 I think it was forty six hundred
dollars was 9 600. he said he's a poor
people
he used evangelicals why conservative
evangelicals he used he's campaigning
Jesus talked about how we helped the
poor blah blah blah blah he wasn't his
whole deal
when it came time to vote what you think
happened
lost
65-35 so the same folk Who Loved Jesus
the Same folk who holla oh I'm pro-life
and I love me some Jesus and I'm an
Evangelical no when it came to that no
they voted with a pocketbook because
they were saying ah those broke poor
people a republican Governor a
conservative Evangelical they said no no
it's not pocketbook
problem we have in this country is we
are frauds we talk about we care about
the poor
we are fraudulent I agree that both
sides and what happens is I say in
America yeah I said America that
includes everybody and the pro and and
so what then happens is our economic
policies screw them and then we go why
you should pull yourself up by your own
bootstraps when the reality is you think
some politicians don't want to get
blacks out of their financials some of
these bad communities you don't think
they want them to let me become
independent making money you think some
people would like to keep them where
they're at let me be clear
in America
yes
in America yes
because it's reflected in our policies
talked to have Reverend William borrow
from the Publishers campaign so so and
this is not just it's reflected and it's
not just race Roland is that just race
Roland look because it's more broke
white folks in America than black
when you run a when you run a a business
and you have 40 000 agents Nationwide
and they're Hispanic uh 54 Hispanic uh
African-American this is our business I
have offices in Memphis I have offices
in Mississippi okay I have offices in
Chicago I have offices in uh uh you know
South Side I can't go offices in uh I
was just on Calverton where's Calverton
is in um where's Calverton calverton's
in Baltimore or DC have offices in I go
to all that have offices in Tallahassee
have offices everywhere okay and I go
visit these places okay because it's
what I need to do to go check on these
uh these folks you have to realize
60 of our company
they're Democrats okay
they ain't got nothing to do what I'm
talking about but it but it does to me
because of course it does well yeah
you're saying in a sarcastic way I'll
tell you in my way because I want to
find out what we can do to improve and
if the data improves Republican policies
are doing better which they haven't had
a chance to do because they haven't had
the vote for that's a lot
Republicans haven't won
I don't think you understand if you're a
Republican and you win is the
African-American Trump made a lot of
progress in your community
for where for where
income you want me to pull up the stats
for you pull it up with a net loss of
Jobs net loss of jobs you're counting
Kobe don't do that when you count wait
stop don't bring up
wait a minute so you don't bring up code
oh my God
what you just did that's a valid day for
three what you just did validates why
that article about the appraisals being
this that's exactly what you just did no
it's not it doesn't tell the whole story
here's the deal right here here's the
deal I love this year this is what I
love about this I love about when people
again go oh let's take out what happened
I know he was President not just him uh
same thing Obama if we take out 2009
okay oh my God this is what it looks
like I can't ignore 09 and o10 and 10.
we can't go well my goodness I know we
had a war when FDR was president look
when you the president you get the good
and you get the bad
the assessment is overall so so so
pre-pre Global pandemic he wasn't
helping African Americans he didn't he
was
unemployment everything wasn't going up
during Trump in the first years so once
the pandemic hit
are we now saying that the President is
responsible and gets credit for
unemployment and of being low are we
saying that I'm saying every policy that
he was doing to help African Americans
no what you said you said
I said name the policy you said
unemployment rate that's not a policy
because the reality right now is
unemployment rate right now at as low as
54 years including Trump the black
unemployment rate lowest in 54 years
including Trump I'm asking you said
Trump helping policies I'm asking what
policy I didn't say policies I said help
helping African-Americans all know you
said policies can you name them can you
name them
I said 59 years got it you've had this
vote and how come you haven't made a
bigger progress so in the same 59 years
you're going to say Republicans
the next question if a republican wins
are black folks still constituents of
course okay sure so when Republicans
have one yeah
show me again Republicans yeah whether
we're talking about State City County
State Governor or legislature and
Congress show me how lives of black
people have improved I've asked you
there are 10 or more Southern States
when you turn on every single news and
every single personality that says
Republican doesn't want the good for you
it's the Democrats that are here to help
you here's the deal yeah there's there
you've had 59 years and Republicans in
the same 59 years have been elected and
what did they do two percent of the vote
you've had for 59 years in the same 59
years they've won yeah and but you can't
but you simply ignoring that but how
much has improved 27 out of 39 and I'm
asking you in this in those same cities
in those same States who are still
constituents yeah here's what here's the
think that again and this is what was
you for some reason I don't know like
there's a block in your brain
if you are Republican and I've said this
to African-Americans you vote for
somebody and your person don't win you
are still a constituent
and the reality is you are so you're
still a constituent it's so funny
because Ted Cruz gave an interview
yesterday yeah when he was jammed up
about by Margaret Brennan about Ted how
are you supporting a two-term living the
United States Cinema running for your
third term he goes well because the 30
million Texans want me there not a lot
of Texas who didn't want you there but
we're still constituents so the question
still comes is Senator Ted Cruz what do
you do for African-Americans I can't act
as if you you're acting as if
Republicans have no responsibility
have don't have to do any policies even
when they win even when they those are
your words even when they win yeah oh
it's all on Democrats and what I'm
telling you is what we're dealing with
in this country dealing with is you have
one part that historically over the last
50 plus years
has just completely like I ain't talking
to you yeah I ain't talking to you
that's what you've had
well over here you have Democrats who
have had some policies have had talk let
me real clear because I've jammed them
up on many things
absolutely should be doing more we talk
about rate of return I jammed up
President Obama directly saying I'm not
just I'm not just excited because you're
the first black president you still the
44th president and what I'm telling you
is because you won't answer that
question even in the places where
Republicans have complete control
what are their policies what do you want
from them though you want them you want
CRT is that what you want here's what
would you like
what would you like I love how you just
don't want to throw that up here's what
I want yeah I want them to treat black
folks and Latinos or folks or anybody
who did not vote for them as
constituents they are well I don't know
they're not you think Democrats are
treating Republicans as constituents
wait wait wait no no excuse me Democrats
are treated
deflection
no you're in the La La Land yeah when
Governor Tate Reeves when Governor Tate
Reeves of Mississippi
said and proudly said when I was a
treasurer of Mississippi
I purposely didn't send funds to Jackson
Mississippi
but now he wants to complain about
the Water Crisis
well dude what
you were the treasurer you neglect it
resources
what city supplies more of the state's
Revenue in Mississippi Jackson what
supplies more than sales tax revenue
Jackson but you wanted to deny the
resources to the very same city as
Republican and what I'm telling you is
now again I don't know why you just
somehow like rose-colored the issue I'm
saying is this here
if Republicans
want to be like Missouri show me find
show me but I'm telling you
I don't know how many black Republicans
you've sat with but I've sat with a hell
of a whole lot and they're they're great
frustration is their own party won't
even listen to them have you talked to
Michael Steele rolling Michael Steele I
have not I cannot have a problem having
a mom okay he was a brother who actually
ran the Republican National Community
yeah
and he will openly tell you of the
absolute frustration he had with
Republican leaders on the very same
thing that we're talking about so let me
ask you a different question so you can
yell Democrats all day I'm telling you
black Republicans I got you you've had
59 years and 27 out of 30. have been
Lexington out of 30 cities so there we
go here's a question for you during
covet what state do you think handle
covered the best
well we say handle Cove at the bit yeah
which one which one's policies when you
say handle code with the business you
had first of all you gotta break that
thing you had you had testing you had
your vaccine then you had your mask then
you had your businesses I think
different states did things well
the greatest problem was that they were
left to their own devices because of
gross ignorance coming out of the White
House be specific with the states which
one first of all I'm unpacking it first
of all I'm all here first of all when
you had states that were forced to
compete for equipment and man that was
just stupid again you had a failure of
leadership
so when I look at I look at the various
States when I look at what California
did something's good
when I look at what excuse me
I said I'm walking through it okay
some of the lockdowns they had weren't
good when I look at some of the Mask
mandates that took place uh in places
like Georgia were good when I look at
some of the places in Florida good when
I look at some of the policies that took
place in New York state were good
because it was based upon nursing homes
it was based upon hospitals it that was
such a again the the problem that we had
Statewide was that you had such gross
neglect federally that it was disjointed
all around the country when you had
Maryland like flying private planes and
trying to find equipment and doing stuff
along those lines they were able to get
some of that sort of stuff so you had so
you had Republican Governors Democratic
governors in different states who were
doing things well
wait wait wait wait wait I I interrupted
you hoping you would say it you said
what California did good with the
lockdown you said Georgia mask you
didn't say anything about New York what
they did right and what Florida did no
no what I said what I said I said you
didn't say what Florida I did I said
right I actually did and also I said in
New York in terms of what they were
doing with their nursing homes Hospital
in the restaurant about Florida Florida
Florida same thing some of the mass
mandates and also and again also when it
came to testing what the problems that
we saw again was that this thing was so
fast moving and again no real Federal
leadership so these states were left to
like fend for themselves and I think one
of the greatest one of the greatest you
know most shameful thing is when the
United States they were overpaying for
goods and services when it should have
been run through the federal government
and actually streamline States should
not have been competing against one
another in fighting for equipment when
Maryland
Republican Governor Hogan was doing in
Maryland trying to compete against
democratic governor in Virginia
competing against a Democratic governor
in New York competing against a
republican governor in Florida that was
absolutely crazy yeah but again there
were some very good things thank God we
had folks who ramped up testing
facilities who ramped up who were using
stadiums and things along those lines
and so those things were good but there
were a lot of things that were bad let
me so let me ask you again it was some
good a lot of bad Roland how do you
judge a data specific to data how do you
judge
the best country to live in with the
best opportunities well here's the deal
when you when like when you say that
yeah they have numerous factors there so
you go economic you go Health you go
education you go to qualitative living
you go environment you go all of that
yeah and so there's there are reports
that or studies done that America not at
the top
there are other countries now here's the
deal we go oh my God that's not us are
there other countries better
educationally than the United States
yes
when it comes to our health care System
some parts of our system great I'm from
Houston
Texas Medical Center
uh uh uh MD Anderson Cancer Institute
tops in the country
the other aspect awful
what I recognize is that we ain't
perfect
we're good we're great areas but we are
great in other areas When We complain
about human rights abuses in China we
act like police violence don't happen
here the fact of the matter is a big
difference
okay tell it to the person who got beat
yeah it's a big deal yeah tell us a
person who got to be tell it to the
person tell the person who had the very
family member do the police violence but
go ahead that's don't don't pin the
position as a person not being
sympathetic to the law this ain't not
being sympathetic yeah I'm saying if so
there's I'm saying when you're when your
child or your son your dog's been beaten
and killed I lived in guess what I lived
in a country called Iran at a time where
you couldn't tell people you were
Christian and trust me it's not a place
to be well it's a very big difference
what is China and U.S what what trust me
well trust me I've interviewed enough
mothers and fathers who've had children
who've been the victims of police
violence who will say guess what they
didn't live in Iran but their child is
still dead right I agree that's a
catastrophic on what happened I saw the
video on Ty on Tyree Nichols what
happened uh I had a hard time watching
you know what I haven't heard and he has
my mom Republican friends this year the
the billions that we spend every year on
police settlements do you know who I
rarely hear saying anything fiscal
conservatives let me come back I wonder
why let's we'll finish how about we
finish off with that that's fine let's
stay on this topic here you said judging
a great country right right and you said
all those different things okay great
how do you judge a great restaurant
well
customer service okay
cleanliness yeah
quality of food yeah Ambiance some
places it's the music yeah all depends
on what you all depends on what you like
what's your favorite food what do you
like oh first of all my grandpa's from
Louisiana it's gumbo okay all right cool
I'm good with that uh okay so when you
see what is the most packed restaurant
where you're at right now
packed restaurant like Friday night is
jam-packed and I
it could be the hole in the wall
with great food it could be STK it could
be prime 112. there you go hail I'm from
Texas and it's two o'clock in the
morning damn it is Whataburger there you
go okay
you don't eat man with you so it ain't
it ain't no Michelin yeah it's just time
and place time and place who the hell is
open I'm I'm with you so so but a part
of it comes down and not in and out
Whataburger so well listen this is team
in and out here just want to let you
know
I don't want salad dressing have you
tried Five Guys or no first dude I tried
Five Guys but it ain't Whataburger I
don't want salad dressing on my burger
I can't do it it's ketchup I lived in
Texas five years I can't do it see
that's wrong but here's the part
I'm glad you left but team Whataburger
you left as well no I didn't where are
you living I'm a registered voter in
Texas but where are you living on my
house nah come on now now you I ask you
where are you I'm trying to tell you
stop it I'm trying to tell you so let me
go back to this
you're also paying state taxes and taxes
which I'm sure you appreciate it but
you're not you don't pay state taxes in
Texas that's the point so you're like
the state taxes you're paid I'm just
stating you don't pay tax state income
taxes of course I know I get that and
that's I would much rather pay Texas
estate income taxes in Virginia yeah but
you still have a lot of property taxes
so so nowhere Hospital District taxes
and school taxes would you flip it would
you rather play would you rather pay the
property or the state taxes are based
actually
I looked at both and it's really based
upon no I'm trying to tell you based
upon where you actually live I'm trying
to tell you state so you would take it
13 state taxes of California I just pay
lower real estate nice trick trying to
go to California you mentioned Virginia
and Texas what I'm saying is when I look
at both of them I'm looking at
priorities in those places and what
you're actually paying let's stay on
this year okay so you just go there the
the way to judge a great country to me
one of the best factors is immigration
okay America leads it with 41 million
okay China's losing their net people are
leaving Russia actually first of all
China's first of all they're not leaving
China's one child policy 30 years ago
screwed them
but there's both but it's their birth
you're right but they're also leaving
yeah but but Dylan if you were still
having kids you're not worried about
who's leaving but people are leaving
they had kids you're right but people
who the hell thought that was a good
idea but and guess what the fact that
they can stop can't catch up yeah so
here's the other part so the other part
is when you look at the policies during
covet who did it best what's the best
way to gauge it you said those things
those items right again
there's no best way to gauge it because
that is going to be subjective it's what
do you think was most important do you
think vaccines do you think keeping
businesses open do you think testing
what was most important do you think uh
Mass updates is one reason with you
there's no no reason I just don't I'm
just simply not agreeing with you there
are different ways to assess what you
think so so based upon priority so let
me ask you so you watch sports yes what
do you like
what do you mean while like are you
going Eagles or chiefs I don't give a
damn either when I'm from Houston so
you're Houston see I am born and raised
in Houston I don't like who wins Astros
these are Astros I have to say in
Houston okay what does Houston mean so I
got you anybody in Houston right so so I
don't give a damn who wins so does the
score at the end is it subjective
no there's a score there's a score okay
so is there a way to have a score on
what state handled no it's not really
because no no no no there is but it is
still subjective because that will be
weighing whatever however you want to
apportion and football is simple
six points for a touchdown one point for
p-a-t three points for field goal two
for safety okay that's the deal over
here it's subjective it's whoever she's
deciding I'm just curious what the
rating she's gonna say with this so the
fact that California had its first net
loss to population since 1851 and that
New York lost 330. is there any of that
that's subjective to you
why people leave people leave for
various reasons first time since 1851
California had a net loss okay and right
now we have here's the whole deal I look
at what happens so for instance when we
were taught we were talking about with
the basis of my book wide fear we talk
about Nation becoming majority minority
by 2043 why is that white folks stop
having kids
okay why is that why is the average
death rate among white Americans hiring
in 12 states of the average birth rate I
when when something happens I'm going
back to you and your housing appraisal I
didn't see the data
you have to answer the question why why
is this happening why is the Rust Belt
losing population one of the reasons the
Rust Belt is losing population because
when you get the great migration of
African-American from the south to the
north where were they going Chicago they
were going to Gary Indiana they were
going to Detroit they were going to St
Louis in those places what has been
happening there have been people who
like you know what we can move back home
land issues and so if somebody if I'm
looking at something I'm then go okay
why are they leaving not just oh they're
leaving I can't assign it to covet I
can't assign it to just this I need to
know why people are leaving have they
been surveyed
can you pull up power versus Force just
pull up power versus Force I just want
to show something to you this book
changed my life I I would recommend go
to images go to images if you can I just
want to this this book is a
life-changing book Oprah Winfrey uh
talked about this a long time ago go to
the one that says the color the color
the color uh bottom left yeah that one
right there so it explains different
levels that we go through shame at the
bottom which is the lowest level of
consciousness
then it's guilt apathy grief fear desire
anger Pride courage
neutrality willingness acceptance reason
then you gotta love joy peace
Enlightenment okay I feel like you can't
be wrong at all okay and I it's it's
mathematically impossible to have a
conversation to say I think this is
where we got it wrong here's what we
could do this I don't see a I don't know
if there's an ability to say I can see
how we can improve in this area I can
see how we can improve in that area
based on the conversation I'm having
with you but you run a company we do the
exact same thing in companies the
realities is here when I'm looking at a
show yeah folks go like was that a great
show
oh I think they'll say this is a great
show no no no no no no no no no violent
no when I'm what I'm saying right
because I own a company right it was
it's my goals row now was a great show
to them that was a great show
to me I'm looking to show a different
way right I'm looking at Graphics speed
of playing Clips I'm looking at that so
I may not say it's a great show that's
what I'm saying it is subjective based
upon who is answering that particular
question and so you may have numerous
studies or surveys just like like I love
these surveys when they say uh the
greatest the the cities with the best
food
you go
huh how the hell is that City number
three
I've been there
again it's subjective and so that's all
I'm saying when I'm looking at something
like your question about covet it varies
depending upon what you think was the
most important thing that's all I'm
saying so I'm not saying that city was
awful first time California has lost its
population since 1851 you said because
whites are not having babies no no no no
that's not what I said would I notice
that what I said
say again now what did you say no what
did you say are you actually actively
listening I am 100 this is what I'm
saying what I'm saying is when something
happens yeah like losing this
eczema people sense this my first thing
is hmm
why
you haven't said that you haven't said
it why it's the second question we you
got to be deeper than muscles on a hot
dog okay yeah when that again for me
when I see something I go why when I saw
when I remember watching 60 Minutes in
China's one child uh deal I was kind of
like and I look good right now but trust
me it's gonna catch up so a couple
months ago when I saw they were
complaining about the lack of folks
working in manufacturing facilities and
I was like
you can you can trace what's happening
with China's population right now
to that one child policy because that's
30 years of kids and never being born so
what I'm saying is we got to be deeper
than just throw it out there we try to
we gotta ask the question why possible
I've been asking you it's not true why
questions when you threw out crime well
I walked through when you what is hold
on
a question I specifically say it I asked
here are the reasons why why it's
Austin's fault it's Republicans it's not
State's fault it's this there was no
answer so it wasn't you just didn't like
the answer that I don't like the answers
I'm genuinely trying to find out what
policies are going to make this better
or step out of the way and that's what
happens I told you you asked the
question and I say it Point Blank if
you're talking about how do you impact
African Americans and how do you change
I walk you through four of them I was
very specific
economics
education stomach was your first well
obviously systemic because systemic is
actually what's driving the driving the
macro okay yeah so you got to deal with
that you got to so again economics you
got to deal with health yeah education
housing those are the fundamentals for
during the first reconstruction period
after slavery 10 to 12 years
1865 to 1877
you had probably the greatest growth if
you will in terms of African-American
community
but didn't last long because the Great
Compromise of 1877 which then ushered in
Jim Crow for 92 years then you get your
second reconstruction which was the
black Freedom Movement some called the
Civil Rights Movement 1955 to 1968.
those were laws being changed in the
first one 13th 14th 15th amendment in
the second Civil Rights Act Voting
Rights Act Fair Housing Act the problem
with those two is that economics wasn't
one the free the Freeman's Freedmen's
Bank was created in the Reconstruction
period guess what what is now estimated
based upon here in Lewis skip case
documentary three billion dollars in
Black s assets were essentially wasted
or stolen and was never Bank bailout 3
billion what would the black community
look like that three billion dollars was
wasn't essentially stolen what would the
black community today look like if Tulsa
wasn't burned down if Rosewood wasn't
burned down what what black community
looked like today if African-Americans
who own land in the South were not run
out of cities and towns leaving land
threatened by the Klan with death what
what would that look like and what I'm
laying out to you is That's History you
talk about Iran okay we help overthrow
most today in 1953. they were pissed off
with that crap in 1979. you know what
Americans do so damn shame what happened
to our Embassy in 1979. well we can't
act like what happened to 53 didn't
matter because you were 18 and 53 you
were middle aged when you were in 1979.
what I'm saying is when I'm looking at
the condition I can't be narrow in
looking at it I have to look at how that
was created and if I deny how I was
created I can't have a real conversation
on how to fix it yeah but I gave you
four right so Tyree Nichols first time
you saw it what was your reaction first
you heard the story then when they
released the video actually it was not
shocked in fact
um they described it as worse than
Rodney King and I thought that
um but when I saw it and I'm and again I
had his daughter Ronnie Key's daughter
on my show
I'm not comparing the two it wasn't as
worse as Rodney King but it was still it
was still pathetically awful Rodney King
lived
Tyree Nichols died three days later but
Rodney King also died early because of
the massive trauma he sustained the head
trauma uh and had physical physical
ailments off the rest of his life so
but the thing I also realize is why they
didn't shock me folks like they were
black cops I'm like oh y'all thought it
was a black white thing it's always been
a blue thing
oh it's been a blue thing
because we have to deal with what
happens in police departments
I've talked to too many chiefs who are
gross who are greatly frustrated because
people think oh change the police chief
you know any company you can be the CEO
given order
with your middle management
Don't Force It to happen in the next
level doesn't happen we have to con and
all this oh we got good you know good
apples and bad apples it's BS because
what's the fundamental thing that
happens in police departments I ain't
gonna what do they say let's get rid of
stop snitching the greatest the greatest
don't snitch is in police departments
cops are skate cops won't come forward
to call another cop out because it'll
get ostracized
that's a that's an issue I've long said
if you have body cameras and dash cams
if that cop turns it off or doesn't turn
it on automatic firing
why are you turning it off
why are you not turning it on in Chicago
they were breaking the antennas off of
the dash cams uh so it wouldn't record
yeah
it's cops are doing that
why did Anita Alvarez and why actually
why Lord life get elected because they
held that laquan McDonald take for a
whole damn year knowing the cops were
lying knowing knowing they were lying
and that video was released we actually
saw so we see too often in this country
where cops are lying on police reports
look at the Tyree Nichols police report
oh he was he was sweating profusely he
was abusive
they would see the body cam footage so
what does that tell you when you see
case of the case of the case of the case
of cops line on reports the body camera
video showing this here
yeah you have a systemic problem
and then the answer isn't just hey let's
have more training no I believe was the
retired LAPD Sergeant Cheryl Dorsey said
there's got to be annual she says every
two year mental evaluations of police
officers
there are people they got a badge and a
Gun Man the power that they have
think about it they have the power to
literally take your life
and go back to work I believe you got
that kind of power that comes with great
responsibility and I don't play around
with that and it's just we've got to
deal with this here because last year
the the most people killed by cops uh in
history was last year
why how do we change it how do we fix it
how do how do we change somebody the
white guy who's partially blind coming
from jury duty and they walk up to him I
think I was here in Florida I think and
like you got a weapon you know I I got
my my blind stick and they literally
arrest the dude
he was coming from jury duty they're
cops that abused their power we got to
deal with that and we got to be honest
about it yeah I was uh I was a victim of
police brutality when I was I want to
say 16 years old Halloween you know
hands on the car and I remember seeing
hands on the car mistaken identity the
rookie comes out of the car kicks my
ankle and almost breaks my ankle I agree
with the the only thing that sucks when
you come to this is there's there are
human beings at the end of the day so
when we have I don't know let's say how
many cops are in America I'm just I'll
throw over let's say five million right
in that five million I don't care how
much we're gonna do and how much we're
gonna train the human element is still
there it would so which yes it just
sucks unless we're gonna have robots at
some point yeah you have the human
element yes but what we have to do is
stop acting like well I think it was a
Connecticut
this is the video he's get on your knees
he's literally his hands up he's going
on his knees cops rear back
kicks him in the head knocks him
unconscious I saw that go to trial not
guilty yep
you're like
well I'm sorry
yeah those kids get y'all see and so
what happens is so what happens is and I
can tell you being in Chicago for six
years
when they came in the Justice Department
cops are like oh yeah
yeah we regularly would call you the
n-word
yeah we wrecked they admitted yeah we
would pick up a gang member and we would
drop them off in a rival neighborhood uh
just to see what happens
okay I know you think it's a game and
what the hell the Holman Street facility
where lawyers didn't even know that
their clients were being held
you're like that's why I'm talking about
China it's like what the hell when
Chicago had to pay out 40 million in
reparations because John Bird you know
took Vietnam era tactics and was
attaching electrical cords to the
testicles of these men to force
confessions and they knew it all of
these years these guys were sitting in
prison
for 10 and 15 20 years and a newest
fourth confession that was a judge in
Chicago a couple years ago uh it was a
year ago
he got so pissed
he had eight cops who were flat out
lying the judge went to the police
accountability board and said these cops
are flat out lying on the witness stand
the judge was so offended that's why Kim
Fox that's why uh uh Sharon Brave boy in
in Prince George they literally say
these cops will we will not
they will never take the stand
because they are known lies now so again
somebody will say well rolling you know
look it's not all cops
but you don't want your kid to be on the
receiving end of that lion cop that is
what has to change in this country the
problem is folks like well you know but
you know just a few you're like a few
Clevelands under its second consent
decree in 10 years dude what what the
hell
and again that is a it is a power you
know what I like the most you know what
I like the power thing what I think by
the way there is the power thing I had a
friend of mine who was a cop who was the
sweetest guy when he became a cop every
year he got more and more and more and
more like uh you know let me tell you
who I am and all this stuff I'm like you
know what I said one thing I said listen
you're not the same guy I said I don't
like the way you're talking to a girl
you seem like a little too hardcore
right now this wasn't you you were the
sweetest guy we had here and finally he
got fired he literally got fired but the
reason why he got fired was for a
different reason was for steroids but he
got fired and yeah that probably added
to the hell that product not explaining
it I am using it not using it oh
Distributing it distribution oh God yeah
yeah so anyway so it didn't work out
okay and he got out
and we'd have the conversation I think
the best thing that if you think about
accountability wise the last 10 years
when it comes down to issues like this
no invention has been more to hold
everybody accountable than camera phones
I think about what that's done the fact
that you are able to record and you see
the story and the camera on the cops
let's say that's well we all getting a
lot better I mean the first police
department it was real to California and
when they went to buy the camera body
cameras there was a 70s I think it was
like a 77 percent drop in the number of
um reports filed against cop for police
abuse
and it was a drop in the number of
reports of the cops claiming folks were
attacking them yes because you get the
camera great I love that the pro the the
problem the problem that we still so so
but here's the deal but the cameras are
not the Panacea they are a tool but
what's not would you say about the phone
but what's not happening in various
States like Arizona oh we're going to
pass laws you can't record us
see now it's like now it's a or or no no
what do they say their reason is it's
it's always a BS reason but we know why
what happens is you don't want to get
recorded and so and look it was and we
talk about the power of the phone yeah
I'm flying I'm flying I don't know where
the hell are flying I'm going through
Chicago
that's a that's a uh uh shoeshine stand
but no person is there so this guy is
sitting like on the on the way with the
with that shot in the shoe I got you
sitting there what's sitting in one of
the seats yeah so like he's on FaceTime
I think with his wife or daughter or
somebody so I walk up I said excuse me
I'm gonna take a seat [__] you Jesus no
you're not sitting down here [__] you
I go excuse me
I go
I'm sorry who are you talking to
he stands up you're not [__] sitting
here
I'll go
let me get airport police
I said I'm not about dealing with you
today and so then
okay and so he goes
I said let me explain something to you
you're lucky I have all of the grace of
Jesus today
I said I could have pulled my phone out
and I could have made your ass real
popular in 30 seconds do you know how
lucky you are today
well I said no no no I want you to
understand now mind you while I'm
talking
hey Roland love your work hey bro black
guy come white guy walk by what hey what
he so he now all of a sudden he's like I
said
do you understand I got four million
followers
you almost lost your job today
no no no
you need to ask yourself why did you
decide to just to cuss me out say you
lucky I didn't pull my two phones out
there's a lot of these places they don't
want people recording because they don't
want the truth and that's my problem
with the bills now you want to say hey
you can't be in three feet that's fine
because you're saying you're it no
that's not what a lot of these folks are
trying to do they don't want this is
Arizona I think it's Arizona is it past
uh yeah oh it passed and more states are
looking at that because they don't want
that accountability and it's increasing
and again
I've supported by the cameras but I've
also said
if you're a cop the moment you get in
that car click it's on everything's
recorded I don't know if y'all saw the
story where the cops didn't realize they
buy the cameras on and they were
stealing money oh yeah I just saw that
yeah and they were they went oh [__]
yeah it's already it's a wrap well
that's how uh I think was insane the
female cop she was busted using the
n-word because the body cam was recorded
yep okay and again I just say I just
simply say if you turn it on it's paid
off it's eight feet of the police yeah
that's what because at that point
because well you can record they just
don't want you yeah I agree no no but
though some states were actually talking
about blocking people from accident
which is ridiculous that's ridiculous
it's interfering with their police
official police duty that to me I'm
saying that's wrong yeah there has to be
accountability I think I think camera is
keeping all of us honest and uh but the
problem is after you may have that video
yeah
but still
now you got to get to
is the da going to take it to the Grand
Jury
because it's a lot of DA's don't want to
pitch yeah but you know you know what's
changed and then you go they say let's
say you do go to trial like the
Connecticut start yeah there have been
examples where you're sitting at home
going
look I don't know how in the hell this
guy's gonna get off but a jury is
because in this country
we give
so much authority to police
so much Authority police that people
the human part
which is why and a lot of times
the charts will get downgraded by the
jury
yeah I'm not we're not comfortable
convicting them on first degree or
second degree murder so let's take it
out the manslaughter and so we still
have this thing in America here
yeah but but it's the cops you know I
disagree let me let me tell you why
jurors have said it no no I understand
jury said it but here's the problem
here's the progress my my biggest thing
is progress I think we're making a lot
of progress they're making a lot of
progress hold up why I'll tell you I
think we're making a lot of progress
because
um it's preventing both sides to make up
any stories okay so say the jury says
now we're not going to do no problem
just post it on Facebook Hold Up post it
on Facebook post it on Twitter it gets
Millions on top of millions but it
doesn't matter though if we see the
video again I'm using an example we see
the video it gets posted
they go to trial they found out guilty
and you're going how did you how did
y'all see what were y'all looking at
and so then it becomes that person was
never held accountable then it becomes
like Tamir rice that's areas we need to
that's areas no no but I but I asked you
you said you said it's improving but why
wait so to ask me the question why not
you're saying it's not no no no no no no
no I'm not saying that why is it
improving I'm saying I'll give you my
answer go ahead what do you think it is
because publicly you can't deny what we
saw when the video came out for Tyree
Nichols it that day nobody was a
republican Democrat independent because
here's the deal here's the deal examples
like that yeah it just flat out but but
like even the Fraternal Order police
released a statement which they never do
here's actually why it's gotten better
because I'm about to drive you crazy
it's gotten better because like foot no
because because of activists on the
ground
that have been demanding accountability
no no no see no you said antifa that
have been demanding accountability that
have been going to those City Council
meetings those State legislatures and
yeah and we started throwing out
hardcore right-wing prosecutors and you
begin to have prosecutors no no no so
that's why no no I'm trying to tell you
can you please send those activists to
those 27 cities I'm trying to tell you
first of all first of all you clearly
don't understand about Chicago because
they've been on lightfoot's ads from day
one yeah what I'm what I'm saying is
what I'm saying is activists she gets
reelected because dude first of all the
polling right now shows in fourth place
I know I saw that so which was good yeah
but you trust you it's good she's still
she's done I know what's happening on
the ground in Chicago you only
understand that here's the deal
activists have played a role in changing
public perception
a huge huge role and so we cannot I we I
love people who want to deny the role of
activism and marketing than protesting
but that's a huge reason why Republicans
don't hurt your cities and go into you
know Louis Vuitton stores and anything
like that if you don't do that go for it
keep doing it well here's you know what
I like about what Tyree Nichols mom said
here's what I like about what Tyree
Nichols mom said she said protest but
please don't hurt our cities dude we
understand all that what a great thing
she said duh but how about this how
about this here don't kill somebody so
we don't even get to that
see I love folk who loves a oh my God uh
uh don't tearing thing down to burn
anything down how about you don't uh
kill anybody because here's the one
thing here you can you can run this here
we go and surprising I also please I
don't think you will do I know what you
could do you do you know what was the
precursor to nearly every ride in the
60s
tell me police violence okay nearly
every single one Jimmy Jackson and Selma
yeah killed by cops when you look at
what happened uh in uh Detroit what
happened L.A what happened to Harlem
it's 2023 no no no no no no no no I'm
giving you historical I'm trying to walk
you through
what what preceded the riots in nearly
every case it was police violence
even Dr King when he went to L.A after
the Watts Riots he thought Oh I thought
Los Angeles was the land of golden
opportunity he did not realize how deep
the racism was in Los Angeles what I'm
saying is we we should be thankful for
the people who took to the streets the
activists uh the folks who rallied
around black lives matter right the
people who the people the people who uh
organized and protested because the
system has to change and the system only
changes when the people put pressure on
the system can if the activists are
listening please go to those 27 cities
and demand change
because they also have to go to those
they need help seriously so same
activities contact First friend rolling
to them I've actually talked to them
they're there and they're in Mississippi
fighting uh the worst penitentiaries
there as well where Republicans are
running it
you know what I like about today
I like the fact that you came
period but let me tell you why I respect
that because I didn't know well what on
Twitter this is how it started the
Twitter was I asked and I said hey who
would you like to see on the podcast
next okay and then your name was taxed
forever invite Roland right now you
never want and then you said anytime any
place and I said book them and then boom
by the way we don't even do podcasts on
Mondays but he just booked he says we
got it on Monday and you coming out
having this conversation about the
Trayvon Martin Foundation last night I
think the audience won today okay for
listening to this conversation and you
know what's gonna happen well yeah
they're gonna say damn Roland was right
it was killing them but then you know I
think they're gonna say this man's got
the biggest ego in media they're gonna
say you weren't listening he kept
answering your questions well I think I
think the people the people I want to
hear from are the people in the middle
who both disagreed with me and with you
the people who agree with everything you
say who agree with you I'm not and I'm
just letting you know right now and the
people that are on the other side right
now the mill is they're gonna agree with
me I'm gonna let you know right now the
who is the middle
and the right I'm just letting you know
right now the middle is going to agree
with you I'm trying to let you I'm
trying to like let you down right now
because it's gonna be it's gonna be
rough for you but you think so like damn
what you think what more could I have
done I don't know if I agree with you I
guarantee you but you know what the fact
that I know you needed more than I do
because my confidence is okay I'll give
it to you no I don't need you you're
right because you are right here you are
right here's what you understand you're
amazing you're the greatest I didn't
pull y'all up no no seriously I didn't
when when my publishes she's like oh
here the topics I'm like I don't need
the topics
I'm like I don't care what you
understand when I was at CNN Bill
Bennett was supposed to be James
Carville and me and Bill Bennett goes
I'm not going on it's two against one I
was like Bill you're a punk
I said bill
if it's five against one I said I feel
sorry for y'all five
I said why are you scared so for me I
had a rough showing today so for me it
was a rough showing for you today oh not
at all oh it was a rough oh not at all
you've done better than today not at all
you've done much better than two not at
all no you don't want to hear it because
you've been like this since they're
great well you had a rough day today no
no I didn't have a great day okay
because guess what uh we still World
Champs but they did cheat again say come
on let's be honest they cheating they
all got in trouble and nothing really
happened to any of them and what and the
Yankees have a little sit to them that
they fought not to be released in fact
didn't Will Clark say hell if you ain't
cheating you ain't playing I don't agree
with any of that but guess what whooped
that ass this year I don't want to talk
about that thank you once a cheater
always a cheater
got that broken Stadium y'all got here
my greatest rocket of all time
greatest rocket of all time all time oh
easy okay Elijah one okay good we agree
with that second is Moses Malone
oh wow
third
is Calvin Murphy all three in the Hall
of Fame interesting fourth fourth is
some will say uh James Harden uh I would
I wouldn't I wouldn't put ahead of them
uh I mean I don't know if you count
breaksler at the end probably not no you
can't put Draxler directions to play
multiple screen Portland played down no
I would put a heart in fourth now
someone put a heart in my four Calvin
Murphy but I wouldn't so you don't even
count Barkley for that the one or two
seasons
how do you count okay
no Rick Barry played for the Rockets
greatest Defender greatest Defender
greatest Defender for the Rockets oh
it's a larger one Olajuwon is the only
Center in the top ten in Steels all time
well top Disney one time getting double
double and yes and tops and block shots
oh no he is Michael Jordan Michael
Jordan has talked about his defense his
defense dude that quadruple doubles
ridiculous no Elijah in terms of just
pure defense oh uh do we have a book
Roland if you don't mind sharing with us
your book White fear how the Browning
America is making white folks lose their
minds like this conversation
losing their minds because I cut right
to the chase of unpacking all of this
stuff that's going on right now and this
fear oh my God you know again the not
the other nonsense of a critical race
Theory and this this silly stuff with
DeSantis in woke now what it is is it
folks I mean they don't want to accept
that America is changing and you can't
do anything about it guess what 2043 is
coming you stop having kids it ain't my
fault but the bottom line is we're
seeing it play out in policy decisions
and what we've always it was always oh
economic anxiety no no you have to call
it what it is
and that's not a conservative thing I
didn't say GOP white fear I said white
fear it's real and it's playing out in
our policies because remember January 6
why was Trump pissed off it's really he
kept calling out four cities
Atlanta
Milwaukee Philly Detroit
what those four seats got in common
black people
only place in Wisconsin had a partial
recount Milwaukee His official in
Michigan said let's count all of us in
Michigan except Detroit oh it's real
and when people folks have been reading
they go damn I didn't actually connect
those dots
it's happening we have to have a
conversation again about understanding
power the power dynamics who did
concealer win in 2000 who thinks gonna
be the 24th front runner who think's
gonna win like you literally have no
idea remember 2016 who did everybody say
we're going to likely be the the top two
candidates Minnesota Governor Tim
pelente and Wisconsin governor Scott
Walker who the first two that dropped
out Valencia Scott Walker no like little
like literally that's the one thing that
look 2000 20
who hit the two highest rated Town Halls
of MSNBC and CNN Colin Harris what
happens so again when you run when you
run you Elizabeth Warren runs in 2020
she should have ran in 2016. I think
Elizabeth Warren rant 2016 she beat
Hillary Clinton in the primaries oh wow
flat out she missed her moment Ted
Kennedy told Obama in 2007 there's no
guarantee
that you're going to be hot
later
you run at your hottest you're right and
that's what he did Kennedy realized it
he realized how he screwed it but but
that's how he did so you just can't
fight the scientists yeah the Santos has
to run because he's hot but here's the
deal though he runs
you're running against somebody
who doesn't
he has no bottom people say we reached
the bottom Trump has no bottle
he is literally
I don't think they're full they're not
if you thought how he treated Christian
the rest of these cats in 16 no he has
no bottom he will obliterate
the party and the problem is
his core supporters
they're wrong with him I think he would
do a third party challenge if he doesn't
win the nomination that ego is that
unbelievably crazy because for him
I gotta destroy you of course he ain't
thinking party they got they gotta
absolutely they gotta they you got a
little bit of trump
is he kind of like he runs first of all
if I had hell no first of all when I sat
there in the White House tell me you
don't like read harder to deal like five
six times a year because he didn't write
it
um he didn't write it and we and we now
we know he damn sure lied about the
value of all his damn properties but but
even in the White House when he met with
t-ban because I was sitting here going
this is an idiot he's sitting with a lot
of damn power man you admire him this
much are you out of your mind look first
first okay this is a true story he walks
in ain't no normally the president walks
in everybody stands up everybody moves
this way I always like that scene out of
The Simpsons like I went
so I like how I backed up I was sitting
there I'm like well he got to come this
way anyway I'm like I'm not walking to
him so he's shaking hands I'm like
I can't call this son of a [__] Mr
President
then I went
hell I can't call him mister
so now I'm standing like what the hell
am I gonna call this dude no he's he was
that's crazy no he has the man has the
man has no character that's crazy no no
no no no no no no I don't I told you
point blank when you show who you are I
don't want evil around me and when he
walked up to me I went
hi you think he's evil oh hell yes wow
that man is absolutely evil when you
when you will
the people who you work with yeah how
you will destroy them how you will treat
them that man is that man is pure trash
but the people who care about power up
first of all you look at Christie I'm
like dude you kissed his ass so much and
he still talked about your weight blew
you off I mean just just dismissed you
and they kept coming out for more more
beats who do you think who do you think
if you had to if you had to run right
now pick who would be the number one
Democratic person because I don't buy I
don't believe in the Biden I don't think
because they're openly trying to just
destroy him right now with all these
like who who's running who would you say
would be though the number two guy then
you can't you here's it again if you had
to if you had to guess I'm gonna say
what I've said in the previous elections
the reason you can't even just throw it
out there
so many things change
who is the most if I would say the most
effective Communicator is Buddha judge
what's going to happen you're a small
town mayor dude
it's gonna be hell against you okay like
it not him being gay it's gonna be held
against it by some people it's a fact
right so then you go well you got
Gretchen Whitman who's the governor of
Michigan who Biden was that close to
pick against his VP all right uh and so
you've got other people out there but
the problem is and this is the thing
about when you run
you can look great on paper
you can have all the right it's like
hiring a candidate oh my God it's hire
this person and they get in the building
and you're like
who the hell is this person like what
happened to the person we interviewed
so Fred Thompson remember when he ran oh
my God
Reagan again
they would he was the worst campaigner
ever dudes in Iowa wanted to watch the
Tennessee football game he didn't want
to go shake hands it was awful
campaigns expose
everything about you and again you're
great on paper so Obama
Obama everybody forgets everybody
forgets Obama was down 20 points to
Hillary in October of 2007. everybody
forgets that he could he was not
breaking through until she screwed up
the question about the uh driver's
licenses for uh legal immigrants at the
debate uh in Iowa that's what cracked
the door open
Trump he's not going to win
Biden oh nowhere in the hell Joe's gonna
win so think about it conventional
wisdom means nothing because the voters
at a certain period of time
see things totally different in
conventional wisdom simply cannot
predict any of that so who looks great
right now
gets grinded in that system and so you
just gotta go through 23 but I think
absolutely barring anything health-wise
Biden's running
he's the president he controls the
apparatus and if you and if you try
to run against them you're going to get
screwed because bottom line is the
apparat is going to say what the hell
are you doing you got to raise money you
got to have votes and that's just not
going to happen I just think again
anything health-wise he's gonna be the
nominee and all people
yes you will it's going to be Biden
Harris again barring anything Health got
you it's Biden Harris they got to live
with it yeah he's gonna be 82 but the
bottom line is hey
that's what happened when you look
somebody who's 78. you didn't say
anything about Newsome no Gavin Gavin
okay why didn't I say Gavin Newsom
Gavin Newsom is not going to run it will
be political suicide
suicide why would you say that I'm just
curious because he he can't win but but
assume assume suicide assume Biden does
have a health issue or maybe something
it is wide open that is why it also then
Newsome has no no if Biden has a health
issue right that's what I'm asking the
race is wide open will vice president
Kamala Harris Run apps this is this is
if Biden has a health issue and he
announces I'm not seeking reelection the
Democratic race is wide open there is no
will Newsom jump in yes will Buddha
judge up in yes will vice president
Harris jump in yes will Whitmer likely
jump in yes potentially Shapiro the
governor Pennsylvania yes uh I think Wes
Moore and Shapiro probably be in they'll
be too young they'll be barely into
their uh governorship but oh no folks
are going to run
but he clears the debt right now
but health-wise it's wide open got you
great having you on brother this was
great appreciate you
uh if you want to get his book Robert
let's make sure we put in the chat as
well as in our description so people can
get it white fear how the Browning of
America is making white folks lose their
minds lose their mind and have photos
from January 6. there you go got cut to
the chase yes we'll put the link below
We'll order it Roland once again thanks
also on Audible on Audible as well by
the way put the link to his podcast
people that can find us podcasts too for
those who can't read we have an awesome
version for you you're so sweet for
doing that thank you everybody bye-bye